this is the pulse pen from a company
called Livescribe and it's pretty cool
because it records not only everything
you write on a page but it also records
the audio around you so everything you
say are here at the same time that
you're writing which is really useful if
you're a student or a reporter or you're
taking minutes at a meeting let me show
you how it works in the very tip of the
pen right under the part that writes is
a little infrared camera and that takes
movies as you're writing of everything
that's on the page now the secret to the
Livescribe x' magic is the paper that
you write on you have to use special
paper and if you look really closely at
this paper you'll see that it's covered
in little tiny dots and the pattern of
dots on every part of the page is unique
so as the pen moves over the page
writing the words that you understand
the little infrared camera inside the
pen is looking at those dots and
figuring out exactly where on the page
it is and recording the coordinates of
your line now as long as you're writing
on this special paper the pen will
record every line you put down with the
Livescribe pen it gets even better
because while the pen is recording
everything that you write it can also
record the audio through a little
microphone here on the Pens face the
little controls printed on the bottom of
every piece of Livescribe paper and
because the pen knows where it is on
each page all you have to do is tap on
those controls to tell it what to do so
I'm going to tap on the record button
and it will start recording audio now I
can write things and as I'm writing I
can be talking and it will be recording
everything that I say along with a
synchronized record of what I'm writing
on the page if I want to play back the
audio for something that I've recorded
all I have to do is tap on the page at
the spot where I was writing
later on you can plug the pen into a
special cradle and sync with your
computer so it will upload every page
that you've written in all the audio you
can listen to the recordings and look at
the text on-screen and you can even
upload it to live scribes website where
you can just view it yourself and keep
it private or you can share it with the
whole world if you check the Livescribe
website in fact there are lots of
stories and class notes and reviews and
interactive drawings and things like
that that you can look at they're like
little movies where you can actually
watch people drawing pictures or writing
notes as they tell a story or as they as
they tell you about something the pulse
pen cost about a hundred fifty bucks for
a one gigabyte version if you want one
with two gigabytes of memory that will
cost you 200 bucks
you'll also have to pay for the paper
you get a sample pack this sort of
school notebook with the pen but if you
want more there about ten bucks per
notebook or if you prefer the artsy
fartsy mole scheme style
notebook you can get those for a little
bit more money about 25 bucks for a pack
of two if you're really a tightwad you
can actually print out your own
Livescribe paper on any color printer I
wasn't able to test that unfortunately
because my printer kept freezing up I'm
not sure exactly why I'm really
impressed by this pen and actually I
think it's going to get even better
because it's built on an open Java
platform and apparently there are over
3000 developers who have already signed
up to create new applications that work
with the pen so this year we should see
lots more cool applications and lots
more things you can do with it bottom
line this is a great pen for students or
journalists it's also actually a lot of
fun for kids my daughter who is 7 years
old
loves to play with it while she
scribbled all over the page and makes
crazy sounds or draws pictures and tell
stories at the same time so I highly
recommend this pen